all right maria yes maria uh where'd you
grow up where are you from originally um
i'm from santa rosa california santa
rosa up north yeah and uh tell me about
your family growing up you had both your
mom and dad um
i didn't have my dad up until recently
um
i had my mom but i was in and out of
foster homes
um so i really didn't have them i had
them in my life i had my mom in my life
but my dad
just until recently i didn't have my
money but you were in foster
yeah i was in foster homes
why did your mom lose you um because she
was a really bad alcoholic and she did
drugs
and um
she was always getting raided by the
cops she's old drugs
so how was the foster system for you
um
it wasn't as bad as
some stories that i heard but um
i stayed with the same foster family
like more or less
the whole time that i was there which is
up until 13 because at 13 i tried to
kill myself
and they sort of just washed their hands
at me after that
you tried to kill yourself at 13. yeah
and i've been yeah that's
that's where everything started you know
like more or less well actually it
started before then but
that's where it really got intense
and you've tried suicide since then as
well um
well
not anytime like recently recently
but um
about
15 years about maybe about 10 years back
was the last time i tried and i was on
life support
because actually like i took a whole
bottle of pills
i took a whole bottle of pills
and so i was on life support
what do you think the
the cause of your
suicidal behaviors
i just feel like i don't have a place
here
in this world honestly
i really don't
i just always feel like i want to go
home
and i don't know
where that's at
i've always been running i don't know
so so there's abuse like in your
childhood
um yeah
um
at a young age me and my baby brother
were left
by my mom whenever she would go out to
the bar
and she would leave us with anybody like
anybody who would just deal with us
honestly so it would be like her
boyfriends
um
strangers babysitters and
stuff happened to us
me and my brother
um
at this one house
there was this family
and they would
as soon as my mom would leave they would
put us in a room me and my baby brother
and uh we were
made we were raped and then we were made
to
you know have sex with each other and my
brother is gay today and
pretty sure that's the reason why so
they forced you to do this with your
brother yeah
wow
yeah this went on for how long
it went on until i was eight years old
and then when the last time when the
cops took us away from my mom
i asked the judge not to go back because
i didn't want to have to deal with that
anymore i couldn't take care of my
brother anymore i was just a little girl
and i was having to steal
food to like feed us
and i'd have to protect my baby brother
whenever my mom would come running home
from the bar because she had stolen
money from whatever man and he was
trying to hurt her so
yeah
there's a lot of abuse
you went to school
yeah i went to school you finished high
school
i did not finish high school
i was really i feel like i was really
not very smart in high school or in
school at all but
i didn't finish school at all how far
did you go um i think it was like three
months before graduation
and i dropped out
and then where'd you go after that um on
the streets
i just didn't go do any more schooling
or anything like that um
i just
after that i just
ran around
is that where prostitution kind of came
in the picture um it came in about
yeah
around 13
13 years old
13 yep
[Music]
that's when it started and that was on
your own or
uh yeah well you have a pimp
no i didn't have a pimp at all i i
that's one thing
if i'm gonna be selling marie i'm not
gonna let anybody else hold my money
that's for sure i mean that just seems
sort of [ __ ]
i don't know i got away with that but i
did
so yeah i didn't have a pimp but um yeah
i did it
i was
just on the street myself and in what
city
santa rosa santa rosa
i actually traveled around the united
states a lot
santa rosa texas michigan
yeah i've been around
and drugs are
part of your life as well yeah when did
that start
uh when i was 13.
actually like 12. i started drinking
when i was 12. and it just escalated
from there went from like drinking to
pot to like meth and then
coke
and that's about it that's the only
drugs oh and heroin
well heroin yeah
oh yeah heroin
what is your main drug today um
marijuana honestly but i do do math but
i don't do it as much as what i used to
because it's not the same
it's not the same
i don't even know why i do it i think
just give me a little bit of energy
that's about it
yeah oh my gosh
i do i have six kids
i have six kids who raised the kids
um
my first three was
i didn't raise them
i tried but i couldn't because i was
like a runner i was run away at the time
like you know i was running the run
and when they caught up with me um
they terminated my rights because i was
a word of the court
word of the state
but um the first three i didn't the
last three
i tried
but my
relationship fell apart with the father
and then that's when i got into smoking
crack
um but
they're grown now
they all are they're all grown they're
all over 20 years old
have you been in love before have you
been in love yeah
um
yeah i have been
i think
i don't
i have been but when i was younger i
think it was love i'm not really sure
if it was like whatever is lust but um
yeah
i'm pretty sure
it was one of them
pretty sure it was love but i've
that's what i think
i need to work on while i'm you know in
this life is unconditional love because
i don't
i thought that i like might have
experienced it with my kids but
i don't know it's hard
do you feel like you were loved as a
child
um no
no but no
that could be the core of it i don't
i don't and today do you have friends
today
um
i would call them acquaintances because
like on the street you really don't got
friends you really don't um
either got family or you don't got
anybody on the streets honestly because
you can't trust anybody i can't trust
anybody in the streets i can't
with the stuff that's happened to me i
can't
look what kind of things gone through
i've been raped
uh i was put in a coma and um
i woke up with a brain aneurysm
because the guy who
beat me he beat me he hit me so hard my
brain stopped
so um
the doctors wanted me to go back but i
never went back because i'm afraid i
don't trust doctors i don't trust
anybody you know like it's really hard
so um
i supposed to go back
to see the doctors but i never went back
i just haven't went back to the doctors
at all yeah i'm afraid of them and
like the prostitution that you're doing
i mean you would say you're doing it
just to support your drug habit
um i think it's just i'm doing it to
survive at this point
i'm doing it to survive um it's either
that
or
i'm gonna die of starvation out here or
something else probably i don't
most likely yeah
i'm doing it just out of
necessary
not for my drugs because honestly out
here
we've really girls really don't need to
buy drugs honestly
anymore you know what i'm saying like
you just the tricks have the drugs
yeah i guess you can say that they
provide it freely honestly
um
i'm doing i honestly i'm doing it just
to survive
just to make it through the day
just to
make it to the next day honestly to have
a
that food and a hotel room huh food in
the motel room yeah um
yeah if i even even if i do that much
because i really
i'm
out there but it's like
i have the same people
like the same ones i try not to go to
too many new people because i don't
trust them and i've had really bad
experiences like i said like
um
i was put in a coma i was like raped
i was raped when i was sleeping didn't
know about it until like
a few days later because like
it was just it was bad
the person who raped me um left an
object up inside me i didn't even know
until a few days later and i almost died
you know it was crazy
but there's just like a lot of things
that have happened to me you know like
i don't know she said him
i don't know just traumatized me i'm
traumatized now
and i don't think i'll ever be in
any kind of productive or like
successful relationship i don't think
that that's for me in this life honestly
i don't
what kind of emotions do you go through
um
i i what kind of emotions i go through i
don't like myself very much
i don't because i didn't do what i was
supposed to do in this life you know
i don't think i did
what do you feel is your biggest regret
not being the mom that i needed to be to
my kids
that's
that's a hard one
you still talk to your kids
i do but
they're um
really upset at me but that's okay
because
they're allowed to be
you know they're allowed to be because i
didn't do my job
and that's why i'm trying to like get
off of the mat
i'm trying i'm trying because i want to
meet my grandchildren
and before i die i want to meet my
grandchildren i want to
because i i see bits and pieces of me
and my mom in them and it's like
i want them to remember me not as a
memory but you know i want them to
remember me and i want to be able to
give them something
positive
to remember me by
and to walk in this life with
do you feel like you're
walking in your mom's footsteps kind of
exactly
if not worse i become worse
because like
i just don't even call my kids because i
don't even really want them to miss me
if anything happens because i don't want
them
their life to be like
i don't know i just don't want to like
[ __ ] up their lives you know
everything i seem to touch i
turn to [ __ ] it seems like
yeah
i just tell me about the guys that pick
you up
do you like them dude um some of them
some of them are really really
they become like honestly not friends
but they become you know people that
like i become comfortable with enough to
like
continue to call
but then some of them like
they're just nightmares
it's like red plane rushing roulette
when you get into a car because you
don't know what you're going to get
honestly at that point yeah
yeah
do you get desensitized to all the
dangers that are out there
and you just you just kind of boldly do
it anyway
i think that after a while
it becomes like um
not necessarily normal but like uh
yeah i guess you can say like normal
or i just have to like accept it
yeah i mean crystal meth helps you
it does it does it does but uh
marijuana is like my liquid courage
honestly it opens me up and it relaxes
me and i'm not as uptight
[Music]
but yeah
crystal honestly
makes me aggressively angry
it does
like if i do too much of it it does
and i've been working on like my anger
because i woke up from the coma with
i don't know i was just really angry
when i woke up
and it just hasn't went away
what do you think's the most
misunderstood thing about girls that do
what you do um
people don't realize that
that we were
more or less like
in a sense like
drawn to this world you know like we're
pushed into the world like my mom did
the same thing
she's the same thing i remember when she
would just
i remember i remember
she was bringing home different guys
every single night i remember
like when i was with her
i remember
i don't know
what was the best time of your life
the best time in my life
is um when i had my babies when i had my
son marco
that that was my fourth baby
and i actually like um
i looked at him and actually he made me
want to be a mom
that was one of the best times of my
life
do you feel like there's any way that
you could
quit get out
here my dad says that i suffer only
because i want to
which is true yeah we all do that
yeah
to be able to put up with all the all
the hustlers and all the
people well that comes naturally though
because like i was like born into that
honestly
i was born into this world it seems like
i really was i was born into the
the chaoticness i was born right in the
middle of it i swear some of my first
memories is just like
of my mother was like
her beating up my uncle you know that
was one of my first memories of her and
he's like
this is
it's a lot
being out here is a lot
but it
i'm not going to say it gets easier but
it does in a sense it gets easier being
out here
it does i mean i don't like it but
if i had to live it a thousand more
times
i'd be able to do it because i'm used to
it
yeah like suffering is not
something that um
is too hard for me you know i'm saying i
could do it
and it's like really nothing you know
because i've done it all my life yeah it
becomes it becomes
normal if that's what normal is for me
then i guess yeah yeah i mean i think a
life where you're
you're not exposed to all these kind of
chaos and danger and
you know the other and i'm going to tell
you one thing los angeles really is in
lake city whoa
yeah this is
if you could do los angeles then you
could do anything i'm thinking in the
world because it's
i've
seen some [ __ ] here man it's crazy
you've been to other cities oh god yeah
oh yeah i've been to the cities and like
this is like
the most
like
buzzing city in the i swear in like
the united states because i've been to a
bunch of like major cities and this is
like
this city does not sleep for nothing and
when it does go quiet it gets really
eerie here so it's like i don't know
just
uh this is this has been a learning
experience i guess
yeah like i've been through like yeah i
don't know just
like i said i just met my dad after 32
years
oh i know i didn't say that part but
after 32 years i just met my father and
it's like um
it's really really [ __ ] up because
he's been in my life
all my life and i never knew about it i
didn't didn't know him as my father oh
really yeah i knew him as my my cousin's
uncle which would be my like my uncle
but like i didn't know that
i didn't even he stayed in the dark in
the shadows you know like whenever he
came through came through quick and just
left and it was like
so you're getting to know him better
well i
would like to think that yeah that was
the case but it's not because um my
sister's mom is
she expected me to be the bastard child
because i just came to meet my dad after
two years and they were expecting
all the stories of my mother to be true
because they didn't think that i was my
dad's daughter you know and i went over
there i came here and
of course on my dad's other spinning
image of him nobody else you know i
always wondered
i always wondered where my son manuel
got his looks from you know because they
were so different from everybody else's
when i saw my dad i just
this is crazy my son looks like i like
him
but yeah that's a lot that's a another
reason why i just turned to like man i
guess i was like looking for my dad and
every single man
and i never found him
because little behold he was always
there and i just didn't know you know
do you think that's what
draws a lot of
women to this kind of work is looking
for that love that they never got yeah
yeah because like i remember
when i was young young
and i lived in a boarding house
in petaluma california and um
i lived on the top
i guess the man that my mom was dating
which would be my
my brother's father
he was running the boarding house
you know below
there's a lot of hispanic men down there
and i would always go down there and
play and i remember
even
at like three four years old these men
were [ __ ] with me
and
my mom never even knew because she was
always out at the bar getting drunk
so yeah i think
yeah i didn't have that father figure
and i really have a mother figure it
seems like
so yeah i do
i believe that
unfortunately you know
the non like love from my dad
had a lot to do with it and my mother
what would you say is the most important
thing you've learned in your life
that every day
everyone should like make everyday count
because life comes in a blink of an eye
it's gone
because i'm like 42 years old and it was
like yesterday i was 15.
and i don't know where everything where
all the time went and i don't know if i
have any more
time to like make [ __ ] right i don't
know but
just to live every day
as if it was your last
and to be thankful
for the little things in life
because they mean a lot
all right dylan thank you very very much
it's hard to do this kind of stuff you
probably never even talk about it right
or do you yeah no i don't like to